it's crime and no punishment in
america's biggest city as violence
spikes all across the country
remember how new york city was rocked by
looting last summer while a new report
says prosecutors are dropping charges
for hundreds of people who were arrested
da's are reportedly blaming a lack of
evidence and coveted related court
delays for why they didn't prosecute
the new york post summing up the
situation this way let them loot
and more brazen crimes caught on camera
police naming a suspect
in this horrific video showing a man
getting shot after falling into two
children on the sidewalk luckily no one
was killed
and out in chicago during a puerto rican
pride par parade celebration
a 24 year old man was shot in the head
at point blank range
and a woman in his car was shot in the
neck at last report she was in critical
condition and the man died
former police chief james craig blaming
the crisis on a lack of common sense
well i got to tell you let me just start
by saying that our profession
is in a crisis right now and when you
talk about issues like bell reform
the courts are not using common sense
they're putting these violent predatory
criminals back in our communities and so
that's the common threat we see in all
of our cities
lawrence i know that you were out and
about covering the
uh george floyd protest last year and a
lot of all across america not just in
new york there was looting but here in
new york
apparently if you did it you're likely
to be able to just get off scot-free
uh it's sad one of my first job is
working in the juvenile justice
department
and i wanted to help these young people
get off the street and make sure that
they didn't go into the court system but
the judge was very strict
she always said lawrence you're there as
a resource given programs
but i got to give them consequences or
they're just going to do the same thing
over and over again
this is how we train our children to
know that there's consequences for their
actions
but what we have right now with the
democrats is an ideology
they don't believe people should be
behind bars and i've been in the
criminal justice reform movement
for a minute i don't know when they
decided to shift this narrative
it used to be equal justice under law
getting some of these disparities out of
the way where there was over policing
or if there was targeting in some cases
that's no longer the mission these da's
have a mission
and they believe that people should be
back on the street the
our jail system was created for people
that are at risk
to society and they don't believe that
to be the case they believe everyone can
be reformed
what we've seen in these big cities is
repeat offenders we know who these
people
are so i guess my message to the left is
when is enough enough you know what's
going to happen
eventually people are going to get fed
up and democrats and republicans are
going to have people in there
that are going to be strong-armed and
then is going to swing
all the far to the right and democrats
are going to be really mad but that's
going to come
when people get fed up with their
conditions
where do the business owners go to get
their justice well
definitely not from the media and not
from uh the democrats look
it used to be that crime like represent
reflected everyday
existence like you know there'd be a
random theft here or a fight in a bar
over a girl today it reflects a rancid
neglected environment right it's like
where mad men
roam the streets and people get attacked
with ice picks
it's like every you hear a new weapon
that happened to one of eric adams's
volunteers
but this happens and because the
the left and what's coming out of
academia are re
reinterpreting actual heartfelt
assistance as oppression
so when andrew wang at a debate says
look we really need to get these folks
off the street and into hospitals
because they're hurting themselves and
hurting others
you get some idiot like michelle
goldberg at the new york times
who claims that that's somehow selfish
and that it's it's like alienating you
can't have two thoughts in your head you
want to help the homeless you also want
to help the citizens
so the real obstacle is that the media
who portrays concern
for families and businesses has a lack
of compassion or in a sense they're
weaponizing compassion
to stifle speech and then that that
reflects
i mean that what that reflex allows for
is no
adult solution right there's no response
the only way
forward is down so i wrote my notes i
have three this is four reasons one
uh the abandonment of incentives we
talked about that prison and bail
were incentives to keep your nose clean
the twisted liberal
view that somehow it's a moral right to
lead a destructive
mentally deranged life on the streets
but then you have finally the woke
distraction mayors and governors and
bureaucracy
get by with this criminal neglect by
waving the right flag by have
celebrating the right holiday
by using the right pronoun by supporting
the right parades
somehow that deflects from their just
degradation of the cities that they run
can i
i'm sorry i'll get you in one second but
you said something i thought was so
interesting i wonder if you could expand
on it just a little bit or
maybe say it again so that it sinks into
me because that was so interesting
the weaponization of compassion yeah
that's been going on like when you we
talk about families who are asking like
please help us we know that this br
the red flag laws all of these things
and that doesn't ever seem to help them
and then you have more
crime yeah exactly if you if if you say
if we reduce
crime and that somehow sides with
republicans you aren't compassion
you aren't compassionate so what what
ends up happening is
that eliminates even the democrats
from coming up with the solution because
they're allowed because you're not
allowed to
it's really interesting i want to listen
to um actually we'll go to jessica this
is the atlanta mayor
uh she has thoughts as to why this is
all happening take a look here
well i think there are a couple of
things that you have to compare remember
in georgia we were opened up before the
rest of the country
even before the cdc said that it was
safe for us to open
so our nightclubs and our bars remain
open we have people traveling here from
across the country
to party in our city jessica
is that the reason crime is up and it's
happening all across the country
certainly not at the level of these
spikes and uh congresswoman alexandria
ocasio-cortez posited something similar
a few months ago talking about this is
because people are hungry
right like they need bread people taking
nikes
it's not like they're not exactly they
want to go with bread instead
um obviously as someone who's a member
of the democratic party i
don't agree with the hot take that we're
pro-crime and that we don't care about
anything
uh but i what i will say to the points
that were made earlier about
their becoming a pro-law order
democratic constituency that is what has
and we'll see what happens tomorrow when
it's the last day it's the primary day
for the mayoral race but that's what
propelled eric adams to the top of the
pack there and he didn't even get the
endorsement actually the police union
andrew yang did get that
but his background in law enforcement as
a new york city police
chief captain and even looking at val
deming someone who was the first black
female police chief in orlando and
listening to them
talk about how we can address these
issues there's a hell of a lot of
compassion in there
but there are also smart solutions and
things that a vast majority of americans
agree with we all at this table know
reform is needed
right that's across the board in every
one of these cities certainly so that we
don't end up with another george floyd
situation i think the problem is jessica
democrats are in charge right now
they can do they can implement policies
to protect people and i find it
troubling
that democrats aren't particularly upset
that the people that looted that
distracted from a movement that was
supposed to be for
justice are upset these people destroyed
their movement
i totally understand that point and i
lived in a high looting
neighborhood it was scary and i was on
who participated in the protest as well
obviously peacefully
but we did have a lot of problems under
rudy giuliani who was a republican mayor
here who has
you know his police chief had to say
actually we we went too far with a lot
of these tactics and so we need to
strike the right balance in this and i
think that that requires a bipartisan
talk about locking up perpetrators and
siding with the business owners
who have had their livelihoods destroyed
in low-income
minority areas how about siding with the
people who are getting punched in the
face
by assailants who should not be on the
street
who over and over again have been
arrested dozens of times
somebody's nose gets broken the
perpetrator
gets a desk appearance ticket and he's
right back out on the street
and he's attacking uh elderly asian
woman
the democrats and liberals part of the
problem is that they're cherry-picking
the lawlessness that outrages them
last summer mostly peaceful don't worry
about those
businesses that are being burned down
but then the
capitol hill riots the world's coming to
an end
and then like now the metropolitan
mayhem the police
are the problem or the republicans or
donald trump if you're listening to
james
gollum carville democrats think that
some crime is okay and they think
some crime is not okay and if you look
at the capitol
right after the capitol hill riots
republicans came out loudly forcefully
and genuinely
condemned that violence and the people
are being prosecuted
it's 480 defendants so far up to 550
people
will be prosecuted by the attorney
general and by the justice department an
unprecedented in scale case according to
the attorney general but in the meantime
you have cynthia
somebody like cynthia nixon who ran for
governor who's a
left-wing socialist and it's what
lawrence was talking about
she is talking about she's mad that the
cvs on her corner is locking up the
laundry detergent and it's not just the
laundry detergent
the ice cream the beer the razor blades
hair care products and you name it she
said so many families can't make ends
meet right now
i can't imagine thinking that the way to
solve the problem of p
people stealing basic necessities out of
desperation is to prosecute them
they think that this is an attack on the
poor
by uh that's the solution is to allow
people to steal
instead what happens is all these
businesses wind up shutting down
and these neighborhoods become vast
wastelands so if a family needs diapers
at the last minute that store isn't
going to be there any longer just like
walgreens was closed in stores out in
san francisco and they blamed and they
blamed walgreens
they blamed walgreens criminalization of
poverty in a city that has the biggest
social safety network in the entire city
i mean car country so i was not a
cynthia nixon backer but just to push
back a little
about the january 6 insurrection there
are still congress people in the
republican party who say that they were
a bunch of tourists
walking through there and then voted to
know nobody in leadership
nobody in leadership and nobody on tv
who's a coach
conservatives not only not at this table
not at this table where is alexandria
ocasio-cortez
bitten mad about her constituents
basically being
robbed and people are not right bottom
line guys i know we got to go
the bottom line is those people are
being prosecuted they're going through
the criminal justice
process right this is not are going to
be
happening
by merrick garland if you have a
political will there is a way
and then people see that there's a
two-tier justice system and they're mad
hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else